you have the balls to do what drake did
to vanessa hundreds oh yeah what's up
what do you do it's an old uh old clip
drake uh what do you do i was like you
know i just want to show some love
tonight
and i just want to say vanessa hudgens
you look incredible like
right
in your relationship with your girls it
goes drake then you yeah yeah cause
you're not even me
if i was at the mtv music awards and i'm
sitting in front of my girlfriend
and drake was like yo i just want to say
brent job your girl is fine as [ __ ]
and i want to know what you're doing
after this week
that's exactly what you better run
through the system literally do the same
thing that you got
one [ __ ] knife
you better suck that up right and tell
them to mention my name in the verse
you ever seen you ever seen that private
jet that's what i'm saying
you better get us some drizzy gear out
of there so you could you could let your
girl do it i could i could yeah i could
drake's really everyone i loved drake
there anybody else no there's no one
else there's no there's no one else
there's no one else
there's no one else anyone else i'd
probably fight that movie i'm like
you know shut your ass up come up on
that knock your ass yeah like travis
scott was like hey
and then no disrespect for your girl my
mother [ __ ] you
beat y'all beat your ass if i have a
shirt [ __ ]
you all right these shoes suck anyways
actually give me those bags can i get
the friends and family literally yeah if
it's straight
it's only drake it's only drake's the
only guy i'd be like yeah go have fun
like
if she asked me it was like yo listen
i'm like i'll take care of you i didn't
make a job
you ain't trying to get pregnant
what she's all what
two hands on it get them go get them
he's the only one i can't think of
another person i mean no
yeah what about someone from uh what's
that ban you love the
uh what's the band oasis oh
to me two days the enemies i'm gonna
throw them back to you
just running the train with your girl
really i'll fight them
in manchester and manchester united you
don't love them enough then yeah i
thought you loved them no you don't
but i don't even love this i love drake
i don't love drake i do
i love listen i don't love them you
understand them you're right i
understand
i connect with drake so much more more
so than uh oasis
uh i love oasis more than drake and you
wouldn't let oasis
hey oh no run that manchester train on
your girl manchester
united mine's out of here behind the gap
look at see ya
mind the gap manchester doug get the
[ __ ] out of here no
man all right man you couldn't do it you
love yeah that's what i'm saying you
couldn't name anyone else
drake's my but drake's my favorite what
about the baby
i love the baby but yeah yeah that's
that really you know he's small though
it don't matter he's smiling but like
with drake
i know i know he's going to treat her
nice the baby probably treat her right
now
i know i know for sure with drake i've
heard a song even when she mad at me
still suck that dick but you're mad at
me yeah yeah like hey
that's a great yeah
he'll walk her downstairs make sure
she's getting the um
probably get a little gift bag give back
she'll be like what size your man where
double ice oh yeah thick one girl here
you go
here's some drizzy drake gear exactly
thanks oh here's the ovio jordan's form
let me i know your man tours a lot let
me know babies let me know if you want
to borrow my plane
yeah that'd be sick you think the baby's
gonna do that no i think so
i don't think the baby don't have a
plane i was on the plane with the baby
oh you was on the plane with the baby oh
soon first class though he was in first
class all his homelessness in commercial
though
yeah he can't be paid for everything
that's how you go broke
but still like the baby no drake's
literally the only guy
running at my girl yeah that's and you
know what you know i
applaud y'all for saying that a lot of
me wouldn't do it yeah i would yeah 100
like her that's drake
anybody else nah nah no one i literally
try to think like if
like she came in like yo man like i had
sex with
are you you can't think if she said
drake i'm like well girl i mean
with drake like yeah because you want to
know obviously
because listen that's how you know you
got a good girl exactly because if
drake's a type
it's a type it's a type if drake's like
damn yeah yeah she bad yeah
maybe adam sandler my girl's like god
my girl was like
[Applause]
what other icons could take a stab at my
girl i would be offended adam sandler
i'll be so sad i'll be so upset i'm like
hold on man the longest
see if we can make cameo in grown-ups
when you're done
she's like what sitting there crying and
[ __ ]
like here so what do you say about
jordan what he's handsome
he's not legend status yet though you
know he also grew up kind of nerdy
yeah in the community yeah yeah he was
super nerdy
oh really yeah yeah cornball what's
wrong i mean drake grew up nerdy didn't
he
yeah there's something about drake
though right he's swag you know what you
know like michael b is like you can't
tell like
he's like trying to be all sexy how
about you tell me he's like okay
like drake it just stays the same you
know you know
he's cool no matter why yeah yeah he's
so dope
and that's that toronto bench have you
ever seen that
dude so what if he was like yeah you can
bring your man to come chill with the
badger
oh dude it's so big you won't even know
dude
babe have fun i'm like hey which one's
the source for the
youtube videos i'll be in that pool i'll
be in that guy
just really just think i'm like yo man
you mind if i check out your shoe
collection
he's like yeah i'll be on a second all
right have fun oh yeah yeah yeah do you
think dude
he's like order whatever you want i'm
like oh hell yeah the chef is already in
the kitchen you guys chef already dumped
his feet's all propped up you mind if i
shoot around in
your record yeah do whatever you want
man my my place is yours
i feel like you would say that right my
place yours man me and your girl gonna
go back here
my place is yours like thanks dude is
that the better one the toronto house
yeah
that's the house i thought the calabasas
one was like no the toronto's the the
big boy
the toronto's the the walls that he put
around oh that's the toronto
yeah someone tried to break in yesterday
really yeah a woman like a metal pipe
and a woman a knife
trying to break in and she ended up
attacking one of his bodyguards but she
didn't get past the gate
it was so funny is it would be a woman
to break into the drinks that's the same
only women are trying to break it yeah
only women are trying to break in
so it's seven mil i thought it'd be more
than no it's 100
100 ml it has to be yeah that means it's
100 mil
because yeah what did he do he had a
custom built and where it's at in
toronto is like the brentwood of toronto
and the walls for security are so high
that there's a
like even where i live like you i
couldn't build 14
foot wall you see because it's like the
you see my walls yeah they're 12.
yeah if i go any higher it's illegal
here's those are like
look how big those walls are guys so his
are like 25 foot walls
the city is he's he has the only house
in the city where they granted him
those walls because he's so famous
because the rest of the walls
have to be a certain height and even the
neighbors like yes drake he can have
bigger wallets i know
wow and listen some crazy [ __ ] scaled
that wall and still got it
see how much she loves drake i know
they got drake living in the lannister
think about that woman who got his name
tattooed on her forehead yeah girl got
her name got great
yeah bro if we love them think about
these
bro when are we gonna get drake on oh
that's gonna be tough so
i would love it that'd be so [ __ ] fun
just to get drake on this oh yeah she's
committed
drake damn that's so good oh well she's
stable look at her
oh [ __ ] that's tough that's oh
that's she looks insane wait go to that
bottom picture underneath like that
white boy
no no hurry up to your cheeks yeah it
might have been
it might be the swelling from going you
know what she might be homeless yeah
could you live in a mansion that big not
really my style no right i like your
room in the same area
that's too much too much unless he's got
all his homies
chilling there he said he said he used
walkie talkies to talk to his homies if
they uh
spend the night at his crib really yeah
that's how big it is you could just call
him but that's so bad so what what is it
was that his lobby
look at his crib though that's in his
house
yes you just have people around all the
time i would have to
i couldn't do it no it's like imagine if
you live in a museum
you're literally like a museum like my
boy todd's house is the biggest house i
know
yeah palm springs is like i walked down
like two where
i mean where do we where do you go from
here man yeah like what do we do
that big castle and he's like he's like
don't change down there yeah he lives by
himself
see i couldn't do it he has homies
around all the time his trainers there
but it's like
not for me i get too lonely yeah even
hotel rooms are you alone they're tight
yeah it's just too much just spread out
like i get lonely too it's great and i
don't like when it's
like i'm sleeping in a big open area
like look at his [ __ ] room
i know bro he's got couches on the side
yeah
he's behind so i think it's like the
walls right here the beds right here and
then there's like couch
what is out there naked just dick
hanging out
he got a safe house that's where brendan
will be chilling no honey
what is that room that's the boom boom
that's the boom boom
[Music]
is that superheroes that's not his
producer oh yeah comics on the wall yeah
you got like actually no that's
actually like basketball players too
yeah
and the hulk go to his jersey room
that's that was the best one that's why
i'll be chilling
his shoe room is insane oh yeah so many
shoes
damn uh drake's jersey room
yeah i couldn't do it i need i could use
this shirt it's a nice just a nice condo
it's fine
for me not that big
what about you malik could you uh live
in a big
i don't have it i don't know i saw
something here though yeah
like that but that doesn't look good
that's not fantastic
that [ __ ] is weak it was in the 2d slide
video where he was uh
walking around his crib oh yeah and uh
what is that like the original jordan
jersey or something
what which one the one that's in that
case oh that's the
that's the jordan 45 one when he came
it's when he came back
his autograph and he lost bro my car guy
he's like one of my
close friends now his name is greg he
ju he was like dude look at this my
life's a [ __ ]
movie and he's uh selling a
car to michael jordan he's texting back
and forth with him he screenshot i'm
like holy [ __ ] that's mj he's like yeah
like holy [ __ ] dude
really what kind of car would he want to
[ __ ] drive a ferrari pista
i don't know they're so hard to get you
know one of them
that's him in the video god that dance
is lit
look at his kitchen he doesn't miss he
doesn't miss a big-ass piano
you gotta have a piano in your crib
that's some special
piano too it is yeah got his homies
chilling
i thought that was kevin durant wow
it would be weird to be his homie though
yeah
yeah his son's cute as [ __ ] too man that
og snoop dogg
photo is dope look at that he got ditty
that blue
look at that he got the blue room the
red room hit a jersey road [ __ ]
look at the pool does he have a strip
club in there basically this this on the
side
oh bro brendan just out there doing
cannonballs in the pool
these girls are sticking
the first time the first time i came to
hollywood we both went right when i got
here
so someone invited me to like this
hollywood party the celebrity party
yeah and i'm from denver dude so when i
see a pool
and they told me pool party i came for a
pool party
oh so i'm in like my swim trunks a wife
beater i have my chains on
tattoos everywhere i see food i'm like
i'm in my head
i don't know anybody just a friend
invited me he goes off with some girl
i'm like [ __ ] i'm
in this pool nobody's in it i'm like why
anybody in the pool
i jump in the pool splash around
everywhere
and i hear this group of girls go ugh
why is he so
big how's that
that was your first hollywood outfit i
just swam over
you know what you needed to do yeah
you're right bro pool parties is crazy
out here i went to my first one
because i used to swim at the ymca and
uh look at it
yeah well i i could swim though you
didn't know yeah but again black you
know the myth black people can't swim
stereotype stereotypes so i'm in baldwin
hills right
great like a black hollywood area right
i'll go there i'm like yo what's up
i got my swimming trunks and everyone is
fly chains on
jeans i'm like they tripping did the
same thing i was like
but i ain't getting the pool though i
just put my feet there oh i go pool pool
if i'm i mean if you you stay pulled
apart i'm swimming [ __ ]
i'm also probably going to pee in your
pool you're going to pee in your pool
you know what i'm talking about walking
into the house you're going to do laps
like michael phelps he's hitting the
whole thing you know that you used to
i'm going to eat your food i'm going to
pee in the pool
and call it a day he gonna get a cramp
for eating the food because eating food
because you're supposed to wait like
20 minutes i'm gonna make some demands
on the plate on the playlist i'm need
some drake
you dance around the pool you never get
in it though that's what i heard out
here in l.a
unless you pick up a girl and throw her
in the pool and that's funny i can't
really relax i can't remember the last
time
now you must work out this morning don't
mean i'm not gonna work out today that's
fine
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son